vamos a aprender un poco sobre el
gradiente y utilizaremos la misma
función que hemos estado usando ya
estamos muy familiarizados con su
gráfica sus derivadas parciales así que
vamos a tomar
fx y igual a equis cuadrada x cuadrada
más xy más más cuadrada ok
y vamos a tomar el gradiente de esto
luego diremos la intuición de qué es lo
que representa el gradiente pero vamos a
tomar este gradiente que está en dos
dimensiones y lo que representa digamos
en alguna escala de tiempo por decirlo
así esto por supuesto se puede extender
a cualquier dimensión sin embargo vamos
a tomar simplemente en dos dimensiones
así que el gradiente de f lo
representamos con un triángulo invertido
de efe y esto simplemente es la derivada
parcial de f por el vector unitario en
la dirección horizontal muy bien
lo que vamos a hacer después es sumar
vamos a sumar la derivada parcial de f
respecto a iu y esto lo multiplicamos
por el vector unitario en la dirección
vertical muy bien y podríamos seguir así
verdad si tuviera más variables pues le
diría diría la derivada parcial de este
respecto se está más el tercer vector
unitario en la otra dirección que nos
falta pero bueno otra forma de verlo es
que el gradiente de f es igual a la
parcial respecto de x de nuestra función
f evaluada en xy y luego todo eso lo
multiplicamos por el vector y ahora
sumamos la parcial respecto del d
efe de xy muy bien y luego
vamos a multiplicar por el vector j
verdad aquí realmente lo único que hemos
estado haciendo es cambiarle la notación
verdad
obviamente esta es quizás un poquito más
engorrosa pero es la anotación de
operador muy bien a este gradiente que
representamos con el triangulito
invertido simplemente lo podemos ver
como un operador que dice la parcial
respecto de x por el vector y más la
parcial de y respecto d por el vector
jota ok y entonces si queremos hacerlo
en un espacio de tres dimensiones que en
este caso no es pero bueno podemos
extenderlo pues sería agregar la parcial
respecto de z por el vector k que es el
otro vector unitario canónico y así
extenderlo a n dimensiones pero en
dimensiones mayores es muy difícil de
visualizar así que nos quedaremos con la
segunda dimensión ahora qué significa
todo esto bien antes de pasar a ello
vamos a calcular este gradiente el
gradiente de nuestra función
efe
muy bien entonces vamos a calcular el
gradiente de f
por eso cambia de color y en este caso
particular quién es la derivada aparecía
al respecto de x bueno del primer
sumando simplemente es 2x del segundo
sumando y es constante por lo que la
derivada simplemente es que y luego la
derivada de cuadrada pues es 0 verdad y
esto lo multiplicamos por el vector y
que es el vector unitario en la
dirección x ahora la parcial de esto
respecto de y simplemente es 2x verdad
esto ya lo calculamos en los vídeos de
las derivadas parciales así que si
quieren pueden revisarlo ahí y
finalmente multiplicamos por la
dirección j ahora que a parís qué
apariencia tiene esto bueno como son
cada uno de los componentes que es 2 x +
ok que es 2 yemas x y en esa dirección j
esto lo podemos representar gráficamente
y déjenme
la misma superficie que hemos estado
trabajando aquí ya hemos trazado los
vectores gradientes y esto lo hizo ya el
software y muestra los vectores si usted
si ustedes miran en el eje x y veamos si
por rotar esto ok ahí está entonces
puedo girar lo creo que es bastante
limpio a la figura verdad pero bueno de
todos modos lo que estamos haciendo por
lo que estamos calculando en el
gradiente en este vector dice cuál es la
magnitud de la derivada parcial de la
función en la superficie o la derivada
parcial de la función
efe dz con respecto a x verdad y en esa
dirección sólo va en la dirección x que
resulta de multiplicar por el vector
unitario y por lo tanto este vector es
la derivada parcial respecto de x
multiplicado por el vector unitario en
la dirección horizontal muy bien y nos
dio esta longitud a continuación la
dirección es simplemente el vector
en cada vez mayor o menor tamaño verdad
así mismo este vector déjenme déjenme
acercarle un poco voy a ver si puedo
hacer su min en esta podría ser útil
exactamente su mina y está entonces les
decía retomando quería que vieran los
ejes pero ahorita ya no se pueden ver no
importa estoy acercando y retomo ahora
se trata de la dirección y es decir en
la dirección del vector unitario j
verdad es la misma dirección y la
magnitud está determinada por la
derivada parcial de z con respecto a y
en este punto y esa es la magnitud y
vimos que hubo cierta simetría verdad
así que este vector a continuación el
vector gradiente es la suma de las dos
direcciones verdad entonces fíjense que
no a todos los vectores que estamos
obteniendo están como en la dirección
sólo en el plano xy verdad no nos da no
nos apunta en dirección del eje z en
realidad el gradiente lo que nos dice es
la dirección en el plano xy por el que
hay que viajar para obtener la pendiente
máxima en la dirección z que es la
vertical recordemos que la derivada
parcial respecto d
es la pendiente pero en la dirección x y
la derivada parcial respecto de ella es
la pendiente en la dirección y muy bien
así que el gradiente lo que nos da es la
dirección en la cual la pendiente es la
más grande y déjenme déjenme hacer zoom
out un poco porque quiero que vean y lo
que quiero que vean son los ejes así que
los ejes lo que nos dice es que si si
fuéramos a cómo decirlo si fuéramos en
esta dirección y obtener la máxima
pendiente entonces realmente la
dirección que debe seguir es la que te
indique el gradiente vamos a ver si
podemos rotar un poco no quiero rescatar
lo más
sólo quiero rotar veamos un país está
muy bien vamos a ver si puedo puedo
enseñarles así que en el plano xy
en el plano xy obtengo la máxima
pendiente en zeta
si voy en la dirección que me va
indicando el gradiente si lo ven muy
bien aquí el gradiente nos dice cómo voy
a ir subiendo esa pendiente en la
dirección z de hecho si fuéramos a tomar
una línea que resulta de interceptar
esta gráfica con el plano z igual a una
constante bueno no quiero entrar mucho
en detalle de esto pero pero vamos se
puede ver que en realidad el gradiente
es un vector normal a esa curva que
resulta pero bueno ya que rotamos un
poquito la figura vista desde abajo
entonces la magnitud de este vector en
la dirección i y la magnitud en la
dirección x juntas nos dan la dirección
del gradiente ok ahora no tenemos que
ninguna de estas tiene zetas como ya
observamos es decir no apuntan en la
dirección vertical sólo están en la
dirección xy del plano xy más bien ahora
y yo obtengo el máximo incrementando en
z si sigo la dirección del gradiente que
insisto está en el plano x diego así que
si vemos la gráfica ahora desde arriba
lo que vemos
si viajamos en esta dirección
por ejemplo en esta en el plano x jet
tengo un incremento máximo en z ahora sí
estamos en este otro punto notemos que
la x la componente en x de este
gradiente es mucho más grande que la de
ayer así que necesitamos viajar más
hacia la dirección x para obtener el
máximo incremento en z ahora estamos en
una cima verdad como en una colina el
gradiente de la de la superficie te dice
que en cualquier punto en la dirección
que tienes que viajar pues en realidad
vamos a ir colina arriba verdad en la
dirección en donde la colina es es
máxima en cierto sentido ahora esto es
más como una cazuela lo contrario a una
colina realmente así que esto nos
cobra más sentido verdad más adelante
vamos a tener problemas para calcular
otro tipo de gradientes porque creo que
es importante que quede en clara la la
mecánica de cómo hacer esto pero
teniendo la intuición ya muy grabada nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo